[Música]
el asesinato de la periodista zaidín
corresponsal de la cadena internacional
de Noticias cataría al jazeera ha
generado todo tipo de reacciones a nivel
internacional diferentes medios de
comunicación ongs incluso la misma
cadena de noticias acusan a las fuerzas
armadas de Israel de ser el culpable de
la muerte de esta periodista mientras
que desde el gobierno de este país dicen
que existe la posibilidad que haya
muerto a causa de disparos de palestinos
todo esto ocurrió en una redada en yanín
en cisjordania los hechos no son del
todo claros todavía veamos
el chaleco antibalas y el casco que la
identificaban como periodista no fueron
suficientes para evitar la muerte de la
palestino estadounidense chairin abú
acle corresponsal del mediocatería al
jazeera un suceso que ha conmocionado al
mundo y que el Yadira y testigos
atribuyen a los soldados israelíes es un
asesinato flagrante que viola las leyes
y normas internacionales las fuerzas de
ocupación israelíes asesinaron a sangre
fría a nuestra corresponsal en Palestina
el gobierno israelí sostuvo que la
muerte posiblemente se dio por fuego
palestino pero los Testigos aseguran que
en ese momento no había combatientes
palestinos
existe una posibilidad viable de que la
periodista haya sido alcanzada por fuego
de los palestinos armados pero para
llegar a la verdad debemos realizar una
investigación
a la autoridad Palestina por rechazar
una investigación conjunta
Déjenme preguntar desde cuándo El
Criminal tiene derecho a formar parte en
la investigación de la muerte de su
víctima la muerte de abogacle ha hecho
sonar las alarmas entre la comunidad
internacional con los sindicatos y ongs
exigiendo seguridad para los periodistas
y distintos gobiernos pidiendo una
investigación transparente
pedimos inmediatamente una investigación
rápida e independiente para que los
autores de este terrible crimen se han
llevado ante la justicia
no es la primera vez que un periodista
palestino muere en el conflicto que esta
vez ha terminado con la vida de una
profesional con más de 20 años de
experiencia Puede que no sea fácil para
mí cambiar la realidad de la situación
sobre el terreno Pero al menos he podido
contribuir ayudando a que Esas voces
lleguen al mundo soy zaidín aboacle
el presidente de la autoridad Palestina
acusó directamente Israel de la muerte
de abule una muerte que da conmocionado
a los palestinos y también a la
comunidad periodística Internacional del
mundo árabe como lo veíamos en el
reportaje
los
James solo todas
hacemos totalmente responsables a las
autoridades de ocupación israelíes por
su asesinato y no podrán ocultar la
verdad con este crimen este crimen no
quedará sin castigo Nos gustaría señalar
que rechazamos la investigación conjunta
con las autoridades israelíes porque
cometieron este crimen y porque no
confiamos en Ellos nos dirigiremos de
inmediato a la Corte Penal Internacional
ya lo veíamos desde Israel el gobierno
liderado por en esta libreta allí
dijeron que están dispuestos a colaborar
en la investigación que permita conocer
los detalles de la muerte de esta
periodista Esto fue lo que dijeron
Me gustaría comentar brevemente sobre la
investigación de la muerte de la
periodista de al
jaciradas desafortunadamente en esta
etapa la autoridad Palestina niega
cualquier posibilidad de una
investigación conjunta o Incluso el
exceso los hallazgos básicos necesarios
para llegar a la verdad
por lo tanto reitero mi expectativa de
una cooperación abierta transparente y
plena de los hallazgos y también espero
que la autoridad Palestina no tome
ninguna medida para interrumpir la
investigación o contaminar el proceso de
investigación de manera que no podamos
llegar a la verdad
Pues este hecho ha generado muchísimas
preguntas sobre el papel que tiene
Israel en la región algunos critican la
total impunidad y crueldad que hay ante
las agresiones de las fuerzas armadas de
Israel Por qué la comunidad
internacional no condena la forma en que
actúa Israel o porque no le pregunta o
le pide que asuma responsabilidades la
muerte de sharin también deja sobre la
mesa el debate sobre el papel de los
periodistas en las zonas de conflicto
Por qué
ha disminuido la protección de estos qué
tan protegidos estamos los periodistas
ahora cubriendo hechos Como por ejemplo
la guerra en Ucrania la prensa Siempre
será un blanco muy fácil para atacar en
una guerra y también deja preguntas
sobre el papel que tienen las mujeres
periodistas en las zonas de conflicto en
cierta forma la labor del corresponsal
de guerra sigue siendo vista como una
labor de hombres pese al impecable
trabajo que desempeñan algunas mujeres
en el terreno ese tipo de conceptos
todavía le cuesta a la sociedad y
también el gremio de los periodistas
asumirlos y tal vez dejarlo un poco de
lado y aceptar que ha habido una
evolución al respecto hoy en el debate
de France 24 abordamos esta problemática
y para analizar este tema saludamos a
Edith Rodríguez cachera ella es
vicepresidenta de reporteros Sin
fronteras España ya se encuentra en la
ciudad de Madrid la capital española
allí También se encuentra nuestra otra
invitada Lourdes Baeza ellas periodista
fue corresponsal en medio oriente
durante casi una década ustedes nuestros
televidentes también pueden participar
en el debate con todos sus comentarios y
sus lo pueden hacer A través de las
redes sociales nos encuentran ustedes ya
lo saben en Facebook en Instagram y en
Twitter estamos como arroba
france24_es@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal les recuerdo nuestra etiqueta
es numeral el debate f24 esperamos todos
sus comentarios y preguntas en torno a
este tema comienzo entonces dándole la
bienvenida a Edith Rodríguez en la
ciudad de Madrid
Edith Gracias por acompañarnos en el
programa y me gusta Llamar a esta
primera pregunta El Punto de partida
para el debate y quiero comenzar con una
pregunta un poco más general antes de
entrar en los detalles de lo que ha
sucedido en sus Jordania la violencia
contra los periodistas sigue siendo una
constante no hemos retrocedido no hemos
mejorado aquí en nuestra región vemos el
caso de México que es bastante
complicado si lo bajamos a la escala de
América Latina pero también vemos que en
las zonas de conflicto sigue siendo
problemática
la situación para los periodistas que
están en terreno
Así es Buenas noches Santiago Gracias
por contar con reporteros Sin fronteras
ha sido un año especialmente dramático
hemos comenzado un 2022 hablabas de las
mujeres del papel de las mujeres con
cuatro asesinatos de mujeres periodistas
en apenas unas semanas en lo que lleva
ha transcurrido el mes de mayo Ha
fallecido una una periodista chilena que
fue herida de bala en las en la
manifestaciones del 1 de Mayo dos
periodistas mexicanas Y por supuesto el
caso de sharin Así que nos encontramos
en un escenario que deja bastante
evidente
lo vulnerables que siguen siendo los
periodistas no solo los internacionales
como en el caso de Skyrim sino también
los locales y la impunidad sobre todo la
impunidad estamos hablando de crímenes
que seguramente queden impunes y no solo
cometidos por por crimen organizado como
es el caso de
sino en el caso de la compañera sherine
probablemente por agentes estatales y
cuál es la opinión de Lourdes Baeza
nuestra invitada que también se
encuentra en la ciudad de Madrid en la
capital española también para El Punto
de partida Lourdes la violencia contra
los periodistas constante no mejora la
situación Cuál es su perspectiva
Sí yo creo que buenas tardes Santiago ha
sido la tónica general durante todo el
conflicto palestino israelí no es algo
nuevo de hecho hemos visto en varias
ocasiones sobre todo Quizá lo más
mediático ha sido las distintas
incursiones en la franja de gaza como se
ha atacado distintos lugares en los que
trabajaba la prensa y como Israel
siempre ha tratado de controlar a los
periodistas de un modo u otro en el caso
de sardina boagle llama mucho la
atención porque ella efectivamente era
una periodista súper experimentada
conocía el campo de refugiados de balata
en como la palma de su mano no era la
primera vez que iba allí evidentemente
llevaba cubriendo el conflicto desde la
segunda entipada Allí se produjeron
algunos de los enfrentamientos más duros
y cuesta mucho creer la versión oficial
del ejército israelí máxime cuando sea
modificado en los últimos días la
primera versión no
coincide los que de un modo u otro hemos
trabajado allí y conocemos el terreno
pues somos un poco escépticos sobre A
dónde pueden llegar esas investigaciones
militares hago la ronda la inversa
continuó con Lourdes ya le doy la
palabra a Edith para seguir comentando
sobre este tema y quiero comenzar ya
dentro de mi agenda tengo muchos puntos
para tratar pero quiero comenzar por el
tema de Israel que ya anunció que va a
investigar esta actuación de la policía
durante el funeral de chayín y también
Durante los hechos en allí en la zona de
cisjordania Israel Lourdes está cediendo
ante esa presión internacional una
presión que rara vez se ve en torno a
los temas israelíes y al conflicto entre
Israel y Palestina en donde
prácticamente siempre la comunidad
internacional excepto los Países Árabes
se ponen un poco de lado de Israel por
la historia que tiene este país y la
comunidad judía como lo vio usted
bueno la experiencia efectivamente nos
dice que Israel siempre Abre una
investigación pero también nos dice que
esa investigación rara vez llega a buen
Puerto salvo que la evidencia sea
innegable como ha sucedido en otras
ocasiones pues por ejemplo en el caso
del Sargento que estaba
asignado a una unidad médica en hebrón
que bueno todos pudimos ver las imágenes
de cómo se ejecutaba a un palestino que
poco antes había intentado apuñalar a un
compañero del Soldado israelí
efectivamente esas imágenes causaron una
gran conmoción en Israel porque por
primera vez se vio una reacción
totalmente
increíble no como es descerrajar un tiro
en la cabeza a una persona que ya estaba
herida y probablemente herida de muerte
esta investigación como digo Israel una
investigación porque la evidencia era
innegable y finalmente se condenó a este
Sargento a 18 meses de prisión pero
solamente cumplió nueve con lo cual en
el caso de sirena Wagner es yo creo muy
difícil que se pueda llegar a una
conclusión similar o que se pueda llevar
ante la justicia militar israelí
al autor del disparo en el caso de que
fuese efectivamente un francotirador
israelí como la mayoría de los Testigos
que estaban allí aseguran no no creo que
realmente se vaya a llegar a buen Puerto
con esa investigación en el caso de
sirena boagle
y cuál es su perspectiva desde la
organización en la que usted se
encuentra como es la relación mediática
con Israel Israel responde a este tipo
de críticas internacionales ya Lourdes
nos dice que habitualmente inician
investigaciones pero que por ejemplo en
este caso pueden no llegar a un buen
Puerto como es la relación con Israel se
puede confiar en esas investigaciones en
los resultados en el apoyo Estatal que
dan para este tipo de investigaciones es
un país donde a ustedes Incluso se les
dificulta trabajar que puede decir de
este perfil de país Sí nosotros lo que
hemos pedido es una investigación
urgente independiente e internacional
porque no confiamos en la propuesta de
investigación conjunta que propone
Israel ya hemos visto en los vídeos que
han antecedido al debate como ya había
tirantes y es como se estaba
presuponiendo por la parte israelí que
iba a haber una cierta actitud por parte
de una actitud determinada por parte de
de Palestina por lo tanto alineados con
la postura de la Unión Europea nosotros
apelamos a la Corte Penal Internacional
y a una investigación independiente y
que además sea urgente respecto a qué
esperar de Israel pues lo ha recalcado
muy bien Lourdes no es el primer
asesinato deliberado contra periodistas
ya lo subo durante la marcha del retorno
en el año 2018 en el año 2019 asesinatos
deliberados sin resolver cuyos culpables
no han sido
esclarecidos cuyas autorías pues se
siguen impunes y además no solamente han
sido asesinatos es que Israel aplicó una
violencia sistemática y muy dura contra
la prensa Palestina estamos hablando de
palizas de detenciones arbitrarias de
heridas muy graves con balas de goma de
periodistas que han sido heridos en los
ojos que están tuertos parcialmente
tuertos totalmente con piernas mutiladas
es decir el nivel de violencia pudimos
ver Lamentablemente el otro día en los
funerales de Shiny
que aplica Israel es alto y los países
que obran así con testigos suelen ser
países bueno digamos que no que no vamos
a decir que presumen de impunidad pero
sí que se saben relativamente inmunes e
impunes
estos hechos que usted te menciona
contra la prensa Palestina son
denunciados a nivel internacional los
palestinos aquí en acuden para denunciar
este tipo de actos este tipo de hechos
porque pues al ser un estado que no
reconocido por muchas organizaciones o
por muchos otros estados a nivel
internacional no pueden recibir el mismo
respaldo tal vez a nivel internacional
que lo puede recibir un periodista
israelí Así es suele recurrir de hecho a
intermediarios como nosotros mismos como
le comentaba ya hemos denunciado ante la
Corte Penal Internacional lo hicimos en
2018 ante la fiscal de la Corte Penal
Internacional lo hicimos el año pasado
con la ofensiva israelí y el bombardeo
indiscriminado que todos fuimos testigo
a más de una veintena de medios de
comunicación la mayoría de ellos
palestinos también estaban al jazeera o
asociate Express porque son crímenes de
guerra es que son violan todas las
convenciones de las convenciones de
Ginebra violan las resoluciones de
Naciones Unidas como la 222 sobre la
protección de los periodistas pero es
cierto que que hay un cierto grado de
pesimismo sobre el castigo que pueda
recibir Israel bueno que lo estamos
viendo no en las reacciones de la
comunidad internacional la extrema
prudencia En fin estamos acostumbrados a
ello Entonces quiero hacer énfasis en
este tema de la comunidad internacional
y la opinión y el manejo que le da la
comunidad internacional a este tipo de
hechos ya veíamos por ejemplo que la ONU
condenó el asesinato de esta periodista
lo hizo desde la alta comisionada de las
Naciones Unidas para los Derechos
Humanos ella misma En su declaración
dijo la cultura de la impunidad en
Israel debe terminar puede ser este
asesinato un punto final a este tipo de
hechos y que se abra una nueva página en
donde Israel en caso de que sea culpable
del asesinato de esta periodista porque
todo está bajo investigación
sea un Punto de partida para modificar
la situación cambiarla y que Israel
empiece a dar cuentas a nivel
internacional sobre estos actos que
ellos
realizan de violencia desproporcionada y
que quedan en total impunidad
desgraciadamente yo no creo que vaya a
ser un punto de inflexión el asesinato
de sirena boagle al margen de quién lo
cometiese no ha habido ya algunas
investigaciones independientes como la
llevada a cabo por best sellem o por la
organización internacional belincat y en
ambas ocasiones coinciden en que es muy
difícil creer que no fuese un
francotirador israelí el autor del
disparo por varias razones Simplemente
porque iba perfectamente identificada
llevaba un chaleco antibalas si se fijan
en las imágenes el chaleco antibalas
tiene una parte en la parte interior del
chaleco los que alguna vez lo hemos
usado Ese es de los que cubre parte del
cuello y además llevaba El casco según
los Testigos ella el tiro le entró Pues
en el pequeño espacio que queda entre el
chaleco y el casco con lo cual es muy
difícil pensar que fuera un tiro
fortuito sería algo totalmente
una fatalidad en la que casi nadie cree
por lo menos las organizaciones que han
hablado con los Testigos que esto es muy
importante a nivel internacional
evidentemente se condena pero yo creo
que es una condena muy tibia y de verdad
deberían de tomar un poco más las
riendas del asunto no creo que en el
caso de sirena Wagner realmente vaya a
cambiar nada por una cuestión es duro
decirlo pero es una cuestión tan
sencilla como que era periodista de al
jazeera y era Palestina porque aunque
tuviese nacionalidad norteamericana
a los efectos de Israel era una
periodista local con lo cual
la repercusión No creo que vaya a quedar
más allá de una condena y de Bueno lo
que Determine la investigación israelí
que evidentemente
no se puede aventurar no lo que va a
pasar pero es bastante probable que no
puedan determinar o digan que no pueden
determinar Quién hizo el disparo
Edith hay indicios debido al pasado y a
la trayectoria laboral de saidi taboacle
una periodista ya lo decíamos con
muchísima experiencia en este conflicto
Palestina trabajando para una cadena
catari era un perfil que tal vez no
podría ser digamos un blanco a quitar
del camino por parte de Israel de pronto
por la información que manejaba por el
acceso que ya tenía que seguramente no
era el mismo acceso que puede tener
cualquier periodista internacional allí
en en Palestina ella era prácticamente
una más allí una ciudadana más
informando sobre lo que ocurría y y
informando sobre todos estos hechos de
abuso de los israelíes puede ser que
ella era un blanco tal vez para los
israelíes hay indicios de algo parecido
es difícil de saber Israel ya argumentó
por ejemplo el año pasado cuando
bombardeó la redacciones las sedes de
todos estos medios de los que hablábamos
bueno que era porque había militantes de
jamás o que estaban infestados o que
estaban cerca
es complicado
que ha sido deliberado es muy difícil de
no creerlo lo ha explicado perfectamente
Lourdes por cómo dónde impactó La bala
por cómo se tiró primero un tiro limpio
al compañero con a productor de al
jazeera con el que ya estaba y que fue
herido y afortunadamente se libró por
cómo después dispararon contra otra
compañera que pudo refugiarse tras unos
árboles una especie de seto es
complicado no pensar que ha sido
deliberado lo que nos preguntamos una y
otra vez es si también es difícil de
creer si es un acto espontáneo de un
francotirador de pronto al que le
embarga el odio o si esto es ordenado
cuando hay impunidad y Igualmente por
ejemplo en México al que hemos mente el
que hemos hablado antes
la autoría intelectual es muy importante
al final si acaba viendo alguna
investigación o se acaba llegando a
algún punto siempre suele ser con
autores materiales
que no decimos que esté mal pero muchas
veces y dependiendo de los casos Bueno
pues son un chivo expiatorio o bueno
ejecutores o sicarios o soldados que
cumplían una orden Pero quien siempre
Libra en la impunidad es el autor
intelectual y en todos los casos es el
fundamental Porque en cualquier
asesinato de periodista deliberado Lo
importante es quien ordena matar
importante punto y eso podría darse a
conocer en una investigación si esta es
independiente transparente y organizada
podríamos llegar a esa conclusión
creo que no hay mucho optimismo por
parte de las invitadas en el debate
llegar a esa conclusión sobre la
autoridad de este de este crimen quiero
pasar a preguntarles ahora por el papel
de las mujeres en el periodismo en el
periodismo de conflicto un tema que tal
vez se habla poco y lo quise traer a la
mesa del debate porque justamente en
France 24 tenemos a tres de nuestras
compañeras cubriendo la guerra en
Ucrania el equipo completo de France 24
Está compuesto por mujeres y nos ha
parecido impecable la labor que han
hecho allí vale la pena destacarlo y
comienzo por Lourdes hablando desde su
experiencia Lourdes más de 10 años
cubriendo medio oriente no solamente el
conflicto palestino israelí sino la
región que Resulta con muchos conflictos
alrededor experiencia como periodista
como mujer no solamente en conflictos
sino en Países Árabes
o musulmanes
como mujer tengo que decir Santiago que
bueno tiene como todos sus ventajas y
sus inconvenientes pero sí existe una
barrera que yo creo que debemos romper
también las propias mujeres Porque la
realidad sobre el terreno difiere mucho
de lo que la gente piensa en el caso de
oriente medio yo puedo decir que Durante
los años que he vivido allí y los años
que llevo yendo allí que son
prácticamente dos décadas el panorama Es
que la realidad hay más mujeres
cubriendo el conflicto sobre el terreno
que hombres al menos en medios
internacionales medios españoles por
supuesto y siempre se tiene como la
visión de que es un mundo de se tiene la
visión del reportero de guerra con el
chaleco hombre y no No para nada en el
caso de sobre todo bueno en Jerusalén la
mayoría de las corresponsales eran
mujeres en la etapa en la que yo he
estado jefas de oficina por ejemplo de
la agencia Efe muchísimas mujeres sobre
el terreno contrariamente a lo que se
pueda pensar porque entre otras cosas
hay temas a los que realmente un hombre
no puede llegar cuando se es cuando
estamos hablando de la situación Por
ejemplo de la mujer en el mundo árabe es
muy difícil que un hombre pueda hacer
ciertos reportajes simplemente por una
cuestión cultural porque no se le
permitiría ver pues por ejemplo
recuerdo casas de acogida de mujeres en
Jordania mujeres maltratadas un hombre
no podría entrar ahí a grabar una mujer
Sí ahí tiene sus ventajas y sus
inconvenientes
ventajas y convenientes Edith a lo largo
de estos años hemos visto como ha
evolucionado esta función del periodista
de conflicto de periodista de guerra
creo que un punto significa Cómo fue la
guerra del Golfo fue digamos un antes y
un después de cómo se cubrían las
noticias en conflicto al día de hoy no
sé si llamarlo el respeto por el
periodista que está en el campo de
batalla a disminuido los las fuerzas que
están involucradas han perdido un poco
no sé si decirlo respeto o por lo menos
ese cuidado que se le daba la prensa y
hoy en día para muchos de los actores de
Las Guerras la prensa es Incluso un
enemigo más porque informa de un lado
del otro desde el punto de vista que lo
miremos eso se ha perdido ese respeto
ese no sé cómo llamarlo Bueno desde el
punto de vista de los enemigos de la
prensa Siempre han sido un enemigo más
Yo diría que lo que está cambiando es
que no solo es en el marco de los
conflictos sino en general la prensa se
ha transformado por al ritmo al que se
están expandiendo los autoritarismos los
totalitarismos todos estos regímenes con
autócratas no que una vez elegidos
democráticamente se creen
impunes para actuar libremente Respecto
a los terrenos en conflicto la mirada de
la ciudadanía difiere mucho
evidentemente de la de la mirada de los
contendientes si hemos visto en Ucrania
o así no entendemos una cierta
revalorización temporal del papel del
periodista de guerra por lo menos en las
sociedades europeas donde el descrédito
de la profesión es importante como a
nivel global
pero por parte de los por parte de los
contendientes siempre ha sido un
objetivo y e insiste en que no solo el
periodismo en conflicto de hecho la
mayoría de las muertes que se están
produciendo últimamente y que van en
declive precisamente porque la
intensidad de algunos de esos conflictos
hasta antes de la Guerra de Ucrania ha
ido decayendo especialmente en Oriente
medio en relación a años anteriores la
mayoría de esos asesinatos se producen
en países que no están en guerra no
también es importante recalcar que ya no
es tan importante O sea no es no es
imprescindible matar esto que ha hecho
Israel si es que lo ha hecho Israel
es una bravuconada realmente insólita
porque lo normal con la prensa ahora
mismo y esto se ve muy claramente las
estadísticas de reporteros Sin fronteras
como caen el número de asesinados Y cómo
aumenta el número de represaliados
encarcelados de perseguidos Es que para
muchos regímenes totalitarios
autocráticos ya no ya no es necesario
matar hay otras formas de opresión más
disimuladas menos escandalosas Y sí el
periodista pues no solo el de conflicto
en general y yo insistiría mucho en el
local es más un enemigo abatir casi que
nunca Claro en el caso de México la
mayoría de los periodistas que han
fallecidos son periodistas de
investigación que están adelantando
pesquisas en torno a casos de corrupción
que involucran
hombres de negocios o gente de la clase
política mexicana y México pues hay que
decirlo no es un país que está en un
conflicto abierto como si lo está por
ejemplo Israel o Ucrania con Rusia
Lourdes a mí me interesa mucho conocer
su perspectiva por el caso de Israel es
fácil ser periodista extranjero en
Israel hay mucho hermetismo por parte de
las autoridades es fácil el acceso a las
fuentes es fácil el moverse de los
asentamientos hacia las zonas palestinas
o es una ardua labor Más allá del
conflicto que ya significa estar allí
bueno Santiago el acceso a las fuentes
es relativamente fácil una vez que
tienes los permisos en este caso pues
del Ministerio del interior israelí el
gobierno el gobierno empresa Office una
vez que tienes la tarjeta que te
acredita como periodista en Israel no
tienes mayor problema para moverte salvo
que haya una operación militar Y
entonces pues evidentemente dependes de
lo que los militares decidan en esos
momentos por eso también cuesta tanto
creer
que un ejército que tiene Aparentemente
todo tan controlado pues Cometa estos
errores entre comillas por eso quizás
cuesta más creer que el asesinato de
chirin fuese una bala perdida o algo así
sobre todo porque todos los que hemos
cubierto alguna vez alguna de Las
Guerras de gaza
y por ejemplo yo quiero recordarla de
2008-2009 el ejército israelí
directamente brindó
blindó el territorio palestino con lo
cual se aseguró de que la prensa
internacional durante unos días no
pudiese entrar en el territorio
palestino Esto es algo también muy
habitual con lo cual al final nuestros
ojos dentro de esos lugares suelen ser
los periodistas locales como el caso de
chirin que son los que realmente como
viven ahí y están en el día a día son
los que pueden grabar pueden moverse con
relativa facilidad en el campo de
refugiados de balata por ejemplo que es
donde sucedió la muerte de chirín no se
puede no no es tan fácil entrar grabar
no solamente cuando hay una operación
militar israelí porque el ejército
israelí se cuida muy mucho de que los
periodistas no estorbemos su labor sino
también también porque las diferentes
facciones palestinas tienen controlado
el territorio es decir es muy complicado
en ese sentido Pero hay lugares que no
son tan complicados Como por ejemplo
Jerusalén este o bueno una operación en
gaza cuando ya el ejército israelí te
deja entrar sabes positivamente que vas
a poder entre comillas trabajar pero
claro tiene que llegar ese momento en el
caso del campo de refugiados de balata
como digo a mí lo que me cuesta creer es
que una periodista tan experimentada
como Siri se metiese donde no debía
porque llevaba más de dos décadas
cubriendo concretamente esa zona de los
territorios ocupados que es una zona a
la que no todo el mundo suele llegar
porque no siempre pasan cosas es decir
como bien apuntaba Santiago son esos
periodistas locales los de investigación
los que están en el día a día los que
realmente nos dan las pistas luego a los
periodistas internacionales para que una
vez que ya todo ha estallado vayamos
para allá pero en ese día a día es en el
que ha muerto chirín y sobre todo había
otra persona junto a ella que se ha
visto claramente en el en el reportaje
que es chata hanisa es otra periodista
Palestina el testimonio de chata Yo creo
que es muy importante y no se le ha dado
suficiente
no se le ha dado suficiente importancia
porque ella cuenta como a pesar de haber
sido herida cuando Siri cae ella está
muy cerca como puede verse en las
imágenes y sin embargo no puede Ni
alargar la mano para intentar arrastrar
el cuerpo de sirín porque continúan los
disparos entonces
la secuencia completa que evidentemente
por razones obvias Pues yo creo que no
se debe emitir al aire es absolutamente
devastadora finalmente es un chaval que
salta por detrás de la Tapia El que
sigue agarrar el cuerpo y arrastrarlo
pero da una idea de del momento crítico
que se vivió ahí en una zona como digo
Aparentemente controlada por el ejército
israelí porque el ejército israelí
estaba a 300 metros llevando a cabo una
operación militar el problema como digo
es por un lado Cuando tú como periodista
sabes que el ejército israelí cuando
quiere controla la situación y mucho
porque cuando hay guerra en el caso de
gaza o de la guerra del Líbano por
ejemplo
lo que teníamos era una sobreinformación
brutal por parte del ejército israelí
hasta el punto de que todos los días el
portavoz militar se encargaba de venir
al hotel de los periodistas a darnos el
parte de guerra del día este tipo de
cosas entonces no es una cuestión al
final de acceder a las fuentes o de
poder moverte sino de saber discriminar
que cuando tienes tanta sobreinformación
y tanto acceso a diferentes Fuentes es
lo realmente difícil porque muchas veces
lo que se intenta es intoxicar claro y
se queda con solamente una perspectiva
de este conflicto Por eso hay que ir a
estas zonas en donde están los
periodistas locales para ver La otra
cara de la moneda y en cierta forma
según lo que analizo de lo que dice
Lourdes es los periodistas locales se
vuelven como ese primer escudo de
batalla para que luego puedan llegar Los
Internacionales que llegan un poco más
resguardados por en este caso el
ejército de Israel Ya voy llegando al
final del programa Me quedan pocos
minutos Quiero preguntarle a Lourdes por
las sugerencias que hace la organización
para la cual Usted trabaja a los países
que están en casos críticos o
considerados como casos críticos ya
hemos hablado varias veces de México
pero también Hablamos de otros países
donde no hay libertad de prensa caso
Nicaragua Cuba o Venezuela y otros
tantos países alrededor del mundo
myanmar somalia Cuáles son las
recomendaciones que hacen ustedes para
empezar a romper esos
muros que envuelve a la prensa local
Sí bueno es complicado imagino que
comentabas a Lourdes creo que te
referías a mí Santiago
sí
recomendaciones directamente a los
países gobernados
por por regímenes que persiguen a los
periodistas por mucho que las invitamos
a un poco son un poco escuchadas y es
bastante desesperante hacer
recomendaciones a países que no respetan
la libertad de prensa no a los
periodistas locales que están en estos
países y que como decía Lourdes
constituyen al final
en la punta de lanza del periodismo
Occidental que va detrás o del
periodismo extranjero es complicado no
pedirles que se cuiden porque porque uno
se pregunta yo has mencionado algunos
países en los que con los que tenemos
relación como organización pero también
a nivel personal también en Colombia
México
Nicaragua que está en una situación
dramática México es complicado no
pedirles que paren porque por un lado se
van creando estos agujeros informativos
que solo cubrían anteriormente
periodistas locales Pero por otro lado
su vida vale su vida su vida tiene valor
de hecho parte de nuestra de nuestra
misión es hacerles entender que su vida
tiene valor que no que no vale más La
información entonces en este debate nos
movemos y en esta paradoja de mundo Cada
vez más al alcance y cada vez peor
cubierto porque se junta con una
situación precaria de los medios
occidentales por tanto todo el peso cae
en los periodistas locales en el año
pasado de los 43 a ese periodistas
asesinados en todo el mundo 40 eran
periodistas locales solo tres serán
periodistas que no estaban en su país y
ya Ellos tienen todo el peso ahora mismo
tiene que haber una una concienciación
del valor fundamental que tiene la
libertad de prensa en las democracias y
una mayor presión internacional si no
hay presión internacional y lo estamos
viendo con Rusia qué bien funciona hay
poco que hacer pues Edith Rodríguez y a
Lourdes Baeza les agradezco mucho por
haber analizado este tema para la
audiencia de France 24 tema extenso nos
quedamos cortos acá en el tiempo para
ver todas las aristas pero les agradezco
por haber hecho este análisis y haber
comentado también sus experiencias a lo
largo de esta trayectoria periodística
ustedes pueden seguir dejando sus
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales de France 24 Los invito para
que dejen sus preguntas y comentarios a
través de Facebook Instagram y Twitter y
Pueden seguir viendo por supuesto France
24 sigan con nosotros
[Música]